did you male he'll always make us
something yeah she'll always find
something what is her goal with that
like does she think black people don't
know that the race of racism is this I
don't know I think she thinks she's
doing good but it also she's got to know
what keeps her career alive yeah she got
a mission poppin she doing a podcast van
about the wire yeah I just I don't
understand it I don't understand the
perspective of it like you if you're
you're letting people know that racism
exists like who are you notifying are
you notifying the racists well if
they're racists they know racism exist
the black people know racism is because
they experience it every day like what
is it serving what is it doing I would
say it she's pointing it out so people
stop that type of behavior so if like
you call the [ __ ] out doesn't it bring
his awareness realize it doesn't work
well yeah but this guy's getting his
tattoo covered yeah you think he stopped
being racist cuz you got a set to cover
no but I would say this racism truly
believe it's not devil's advocate [ __ ] I
don't think the solution is shame
because what you do is you just shove
everybody's feelings down inside and
then what a guy like Trump comes along
and is like yo you know what here's some
racist [ __ ] that I'm gonna say that I'm
not afraid to say that party they got
pushed down that's just been bubbling
this whole times like yo that's the
[ __ ] guy yeah and those thoughts when
you shut them down they don't go away
they just get worse and darker because
you can't say anything yeah but you can
also look at it like oh the racist
person gets ridiculed and then other
potential races see it as like oh [ __ ] I
don't want to get ready to kill like
that let me know is it I understand
where they're coming from I don't know
who's right I think this Trump got
elected for a reason and to not just
people are stupid people are stupid and
they take advantage of the stupidity how
did he take advantage of their stupidity
I think a lot of it was the racist
rhetoric that felt people felt like I
can't say at all and they're idiots so
they're like a lot can't say anything
anymore
and then this guy comes along even
though you're probably saying some
hateful [ __ ] dude now you feel like you
can't say anything this guy comes along
saying a lot you're like oh that's hey
that's my gun that's my president mister
guy I'm just saying this doesn't seem to
have worked we've been doing for about
10 15 years and the country if anything
got more divided I I think that that
might be a simplistic view of it
possibly because
I don't think people vote for presidents
as a whole I think you vote basically on
one or two issues most people do right
so if like let's say that there are
people who are like part of the
Democratic Party let's say you're like a
straight white guy like me who's like
vote Democrat your entire life and then
you see like the Democrats supporting a
lot of rhetoric that we're not even
literally not even just being quiet
about it but like supporting it like
yeah we don't want any more white
president so we need to have people of
color that's very important says you
just start hearing that right and you're
like what does that have to do with
being like good at the job yeah that's
weird so like just because I'm a born
white I can't be that's that's a weird
thing right someone like me right who
hears that and then I maybe I'm going
out for auditions right I'm going out
for auditions for roles and I hear my
agent telling me it is really nothing
for white straight guys anymore like or
every role I get they turn the character
gay yeah and then you start to go like
what's happening right now yeah and then
the other side is like yeah why is why
is all that happening that all of a
sudden becomes enticing to you I felt my
I felt that have either like checked my
own self I was like no no I know where
I'm at but why am i curious about what's
going on over here oh I know I'm curious
because these people are addressing the
things that are directly affecting me so
I think people got [ __ ] confused when it
term when they're like Trump says racist
[ __ ] so everybody's like arm races and
we'll vote from I don't think it's that
I think it's literally the Democrats
going hey we don't need coal miners
anymore and then the Republicans going
yeah well why can't we just have some
coal mines open up the coals so that
what they would do is they've given out
and they give a rationale and they've
give reasons for the things that other
people felt aggrieved by the party that
used to stand by them that makes a lot
of sense to me for the moderate closeted
Trump supporter the guy who was moderate
and now is getting pushed a little bit
right because they're just left to
saying all this [ __ ] that doesn't seem
to apply to me and then this guy's talk
so I'm not gonna say anything I'm
quietly vote for Trump I'm actually at
this point right now let's just talk
about the [ __ ] Trump like worshiper
the guy who loves Trump they started
like that they didn't flip that well
until I Trump over anybody else why
Trump Aziz here no no they brought many
supporters weren't like this Romney
supporters would like yeah Romney he's
great whatever he like
he policies I aligned with his policies
more than I do Barack's
or maybe I just don't like Barack is
black I'm talking about the far right
that [ __ ] warship what percentage is
that brah I went to a Trump protest of a
trump rally in Minnesota with Abdi yeah
and these [ __ ] they filled out
the Target Center
it wasn't like these go and they are dug
in and what makes it worse what makes
you digging more is as you're walking to
the arena everybody shouting at you
calling you a racist
in your [ __ ] face so what are you
gonna do in the face of that you can be
like ah you know what [ __ ] you Trump is
even more my guy [ __ ] all you i watch
these guys just dig in yeah big and
that's a reasonable thing to do right
and that but to the same culture of
shame and whatever not being effective
you're just making these guys dig in
it's effective for the opposite yeah
yeah yes now it's not the weeding out
racism is microbiome in you yeah you are
pushing that person towards love yeah
where is the love Trump right exactly
but to fill out that arena there might
be people in that arena who just believe
that abortion should be illegal yeah
going to a rally yes you are so that's
it this is what I think you'll naive in
terms of how you think about politics
it's like most people are one issue
voters you have to allow them to care
about something you don't care about
they care about that thing I can
understand that like you care about
India like you're a one-issue voter on
India I imagine and if one president was
like you know we need a bomb India no
matter what other things he aligned with
you would you vote for him we'll have
what's he doing yeah but for real no no
no I'm a girl right so they feel that
exact way about certain issues right and
then the fact that someone is speaking
up for that issue it's it's just as
valuable to them now don't get me wrong
they're racists out there they're like
[ __ ] yeah you're saying some [ __ ] that X
is my sentiments about race 1% but I
think there are other issues that
they're saying things there echoing
feelings that they have that aren't
satisfied anywhere else similar to you
with the India situation that they're
being supportive of like that's why Jews
start voting for Trump because he was
like yo Israel we got your back and they
felt the Democratic Party didn't have
their back they're not do you think
are doing it for the same racist reasons
as the people filling up those no well
I'm saying is I think if you go to and
maybe and let's that's okay I'll soon
you're right I think when you bury a
person's any like if you want to
actually get a person a Nabi races I
don't think you've shamed them I think
you exposed them you talk to them not
exposing a bad way expose them to the
other side yeah
expose them if you're homophobic and you
get exposed to gay people and you're
like no they're not bad yes I think that
kind of exposure is good but just
shaming they even if you have any slight
racist feeling I can't talk about it all
I can't have a discourse that I'll be
you shouted down now the feelings get
darker and darker yeah and then my one
issue becomes racism so I'm a one issue
this guy these guys are too progressive
this guy he's racist enough let's go
that's my guy
so I don't I don't know racist I don't
think it's an issue I think Trump said a
lot of [ __ ] that's at least to the
middle term problematic and those
there's a lot of people who are like I
like that this guy says it and isn't
afraid that's my guy says what says
whatever says these Mexicans are coming
over and they're rapin and blah blah
blah whatever he says the truth to them
it's the truth so so you think that him
speaking about Mexicans coming over and
raping was more valuable to people than
people who live on border states and
maybe feel as if their jobs are limited
because illegal immigrants are taking
the jobs I don't know if it's the most
valuable thing I think it's a definite
factor no I'm asking about those
specific things right there what is more
valuable in terms of of switching your
vote I don't know why he is more likely
logically I would say policy emotionally
I understand a lot of people I think
vote there's one policy voters I also
think there's the Chappelle thing I
don't look at a person's president's
politics I look at him as a person right
and I think a lot of people are aligned
with that right I guess what I'm trying
to say is like I grew with you in terms
of we look at people as a person and
this is a popularity contest these
people are not good at anything they
have no real skills right right and I
think that a guy like Trump is very
funny and that really matters to a lot
of people and they'll justify the things
that he's funny about because they value
it's a funny just like Obama was
incredibly charming right and
it would justify anything I've justified
[ __ ] that Obama does did that it's
pretty awful because I'm so charmed why
I'm and I like the guys so much they're
so fun right so I think at the end of
the day that's where our core goes but
in terms of why people are voting for
them I think the amount of Americans
that are like every Mexican that comes
over is raping people are very small I
think the majority of people that are
voting based on a immigration policy is
simply I think my job is being taken I
used to watch dishes and now I can't get
a job washing dishes I used to do long
work now I can't get a job doing long
work even if that's complete [ __ ]
they're convinced that's why rather than
I think every medicine is a rapist my
point is just this shame culture doesn't
help I don't think it's the only thing I
turn I agree with you I agree I am
working on the same page about where it
pushes people and how it radicalizes
people yeah 100% on the same page and
you're gonna go wherever the love is and
then once you feel the love you start to
go along with the things that people in
that circle agree with right like an
agree with that yeah once someone loves
you it's like Jojo exotic it's like Jojo
Tech finds these [ __ ] meth heads
right they've never experienced any love
he finds these like weird like drug
addicts never experienced and they
brings him in he loves him he feeds him
he gives him a family gives him
community right and then he's also like
yo we gotta kill that tiger that you
race okay Joe whatever you say and I can
change I can shift my point to that if
you're gonna shame this guy and
everybody says I've said this to another
thing that I may be a bigger thing if
you're gonna tell why people in Middle
America you got privilege you have no
idea how good you have it and they're
like what are you talking about it
working a [ __ ] coal mine
suck my dick and then one guy comes
along as like hello why people in Middle
America got it rough that's my guy
that's my guy so I didn't think that was
the only factor and maybe not even the
main factor it is a factor maybe this is
a main factor oh yeah I agree with both
like race is a factor in everything I'm
you're never gonna be the person that's
gonna come there and say the race isn't
a factor and app everything in life 100%
but I truly believe at the end of day
that when people there are people like
[ __ ] racist groups KKK that a
literature's looking at the candidates
like who hates minorities more I'm
voting for I think the majority of
voters though have an issue it's really
valuable to them
right and then they'll defend the PERT
the person that supports that issue at
whatever cost so let's say that abortion
is that issue they they trumps like we
got to get rid of abortion all these
people who are anti-abortion we're like
that's my guy and then Trump some some
[ __ ] about Mexicans are rapists and then
they'll go I was out of context he never
really said he's the type of guy to say
some wild [ __ ] but he don't really mean
it
he they're defending someone that just
believes the same thing about abortion
they don't give a [ __ ] about what he
says about Mexicans because they'll have
another option to vote for do you
understand what I'm saying oh yeah I see
what you're saying really you know I
thought I had is interesting he's they
say like that you know like the Martin
Luther King thing the answer to hate is
love yeah that's really what most people
who hate they just need some love and it
isn't it is really hard to hate a group
of people that just like keep loving you
I could black people were just like
y'all we [ __ ] love Trump openly love
Trump if Trump was racist
it's hard to be like if fight a race
does not name Trump okay hey hey guy
black let's see oh we love you yo so how
do you need to but like this answer of
shouting down everybody and screaming
down everybody cuz they don't believe
what you believe that's just not gonna
work